all right the last time these two
gentlemen met up uh Dr Peterson and uh
Mr Spencer for the most part agreed they
had a debate on a radio station today Dr
Peterson would like to ask uh Mr Spencer
a couple of questions we'll take it from
there also afterwards I want to open up
the questions to the audience there are
two microphones in the middle aisle and
um we'll have a Q&A s session with uh
with the audience afterwards so you can
ask both our panelists your questions Dr
Peterson you can you can
okay I assume this is on yeah um I
wonder if I could just respond to some
things that were said first of all I I
want to stress um I am not one of those
living in this fantasy world who who
thinks that Islam is peaceful right now
um I think the Islamic world is
dysfunctional right now and clearly that
the militant voices have the upper hand
they're winning and uh and the moderates
the people that I would like to see win
are on the defensive uh if they're even
doing that well uh in many places
they're simply silent uh for various
reasons some of which are understandable
and some of which bother me exceedingly
much
um I I'm not opposed to uh to Mr
Spencer's critique of Islam on many
levels I think it's sort of a bracing
tonic and I think there's much that the
Islamic world needs to do to respond to
the sort of critique that comes from Mr
Spencer um what my problem with with a
lot of what he's done I think is not so
much that it's wrong as that it's
selective that it's a prosecutor's brief
which has its legitimate function um but
but there's some things I'd like to say
I I see my position we're not really so
much opposed uh here you know if this
debate were a debate between Polar
Opposites you'd have someone arguing
that Islam was intrinsically violent
someone arguing that it's intrinsically
peaceful I'm not going to argue that I
think that the elements uh just
justifying Warfare are definitely there
this is certainly a very important part
of the Islamic tradition and it's
something that Muslims need to deal with
my simple argument is that that there's
a lot of material there and it's
legitimate it's in the tradition that
can be used by moderates um and uh yes
there is a broad consensus and has been
for a long time about certain elements
of Jihadi teaching I'd like to point out
though that formulations like the
opposition between the binary opposition
between the darl har and the darl of
Islam the Abode of War and the Abode of
submission um that opposition is
something that dates really to about two
centuries after the prophet Muhammad
much of Islamic law relative to Jihad
and almost everything else was
formulated during the Imperial period an
expansionist period you could see the
the jurist who are doing this as as the
kind of hawkish pro pro-establishment
party
um give me Comfort to the enemy
here um but this is the war party and
they're curring favor in some senses I
think with the uh with the establishment
with the regime by justifying what the
regime is doing but all I really need to
do to demonstrate there peaceful
elements within Islam is is to show that
there are some out there it's like uh
trying to disprove the proposition that
all crows are black all I have to do is
show one white crow and I've succeeded
so in that sense I've got a modest task
here um let me just let me just go over
a couple of the verses that that are
mentioned um for example it said that
that the Quran explicitly teaches never
ending Warfare against unbelievers uh
that is one of the things I expressly
denied in my opening statement the Quran
you could read it as simply referring to
the specific Wars that Muhammad was
involved in 7th Century Arabia to
generalize from that to a state of
NeverEnding war against all the rest of
the non-muslim world is not a necessary
entailment of those passages now that it
has been the entailment for a lot of
Muslims maybe the dominant tradition is
no doubt true uh but I think there are
other ways of reading it for example um
the so-called sword verse Quran 95 reads
and when the sacred months are over slay
the polytheists wherever you find them
take them captive besiege them and lie
and wait for them at every conceivable
place but the references in that verse
to polytheists it's not just
non-believers it's polytheists and the
reference to the sacred months make it
clear this verse refers specifically to
the Pagan Arabs of Muhammad's time in
fact that's how many early Scholars such
as m sulan in the 8th Century the great
atab the greatest of the Quran
commentators God in the early 10th
century that's how they understood it
the verse that he that Mr Spencer
expressly quoted um conjoined with the
sword verse is Quran 9:29 which reads
fight against those who despite having
been given Revelation before do not
believe in God nor in the last day and
do not consider forbidden that which God
and His messenger have forbidden and do
not follow the religion of the truth
until they pay the jizer with willing
hand having been subdued now this verse
obviously doesn't refer to all
Christians and Jews but only for those
who disbelieve in God and fail to forbid
evil contrast what Quran 3: 113-115 says
about devoted Christians and Jews they
are not all the same among the people of
the book are a contingent who stand in
prayer reciting the verses of God at all
times of the night while they prostrate
themselves these are they who believe in
God in the last day and enjoy what is
right and forbid what is wrong they
hasten to perform Good Deeds they are
among the righteous and whatever they do
a good will will not be rejected by God
and God knows best who are the
God-fearing so this idea that it's a
blanket invitation to war against all
Christians and Jews seems to me even if
many Muslims have taken that way taken
it that way seems to me one you can you
can construct a legitimate argument
against and I'm just hoping for the
success of people who will make that
argument
sorry thanks for the pen yeah uh so am I
hoping for the success of people who
make that argument but once again my
constant refrain is in this let's not
kid ourselves uh there are other ways of
reading the Quran sure I am all for
somebody coming in tomorrow and making
up a whole new way to read the Quran to
eliminate the uh Power of any of these
verses and many others that we could
quote to incite people to violence and
to make them pursue a supremacist agenda
against the west but the fact is that
the mainstream understandings as Dr
Peterson has conceited of these verses
is not that way we can make up pretty
things out of the Quran all that we want
but the point the only reason to even
perform the exercise would be to help
Muslims to actually understand the Quran
this way uh and for example you take
take some of the things that uh Dr
Peterson has pointed out that chapter
9:29 refers only as he says to uh
fighting against those Jews and
Christians who disbelieve in Allah well
since Allah La is just the word for God
it might seem nice if you stop there
because you think well Jews and
Christians by definition believe in God
and so that means they're only fighting
against Jews and Christians who perhaps
aren't very religious but the reality of
the situation is it says fight against
the people of the book that is the Jews
and Christians who disbelieve in Allah
and his messenger that is the Jews and
Christians who disbelieve in Allah and
Muhammad the Jews and Christians in
other words who who have the tarity not
to convert to Islam they are the ones
who have to be fought and that would be
all those who remain Jews and Christians
and don't become Muslims this is
validated by many many Hadith and many
many statements of the tapir the
commentaries on the Quran and Islamic
law and history uh for it's very
comforting perhaps to read I can give
you a verse you could use it that's chap
2: 62 which says that the Believers Jews
and Christians and cians nobody knows
exactly who cians were but Jews and
Christians we know will go to paradise
and that sounds great how how wonderful
and ecumenical until you read the
commentary such as that by Ian kathir
who is mainstream accepted commentator
on thean on and the tap J line which is
another one another commentary that is
very widely accepted and respected by
Muslims and they both say the Jews and
Christians who go to heaven are the ones
who convert to
Islam the bad ones stay Jews and
Christians the uh I didn't ever say that
I didn't ever say a lot of things that
have been attributed to me today but I
didn't say that there were no peaceful
elements of Islam there are many
peaceful elements of Islam but the fact
that the Nazis did Social Services
doesn't mean they didn't incinerate Jews
uh the the there are peaceful elements
of Islam and wonderful elements of Islam
beautiful I wouldn't have studied Islam
all these years if there weren't so many
beautiful and compelling elements within
it but here again we can't kid ourselves
there are also violent and supremacist
elements of it that do exist and that
Muslims believe and no matter how we may
make up some nice ways to get around
them until Muslims worldwide on a
widespread basis start formulating those
same kinds of ways to get around them
then we're just playing games and making
ourselves feel better and uh what is it
what's the expression playing shuffle
board on the bridge of the
Titanic